super quickly can you give the analogy
of the icos because that's basically
what it is
because just when it's positioned this
thing has been positioned so many
different ways and
that's partially because it's still kind
of half baked and things are being
worked out and
and it may evolve into other things but
at least as to like what it is today
i thought what you said about it was so
spot on in terms of what this
really is at least so far yeah sure so
on paper and again i i think one of the
reasons that
bitcloud has been so successful is
because they are master marketers
like i don't approve of it but it's kind
of like when your kid gets in trouble
and you're like i don't have a kid but
like
you gotta know when kids get involved
with them right yeah yeah you're like
oh you're in so much trouble but i get
it as well like nice job buddy
you know yeah i don't so i don't i don't
approve
of what they did but they but it's a
smart growth hack the other thing is
that they're positioning
this product in a very smart way where
the reality of what it is has been
abstracted away so what this what this
is on paper
is they've basically done 15 000
icos without the permission
of the people who are backing those
coins right by scraping twitter and
creating an account for the top 15 000
people
they've created they've done 15 000 icos
and now they're basically just trying to
get people to buy into those icos and i
think anybody who's thinking of
getting into this either as a creator or
an
investor should ask themselves you know
one as a creator
would i create an ico for myself if the
answer is no
you know think twice about just cause
someone did it for you doesn't mean
you know all of a sudden it's a good
idea yeah and then similarly like as a
as a backer
would i buy so-and-so's ico it starts to
kind of break down because like when you
think about this as
betting on somebody's reputation that's
one thing you're like oh okay well
you know somebody like kim kardashian or
tim ferriss or steph smith these are all
people that i think are
doing interesting work and are probably
going to become more
popular on this platform so if i'm early
i should buy in
but you have to ask yourself the real
question which is like if
you know if i issued an ico tomorrow
would you buy it
probably not but what the platform's
done is
aggregate thousands of icos and make it
extremely easy to issue a new one which
could be useful like there's there's
potential
there but let's not let's not mince
words about what it is these are just
icos
that's literally all they are